il avait une semaine pour tout changer
redécoré le point jeunes de la
république à guyancourt une activité
manuelle proposé à la quarantaine
d'adolescents accueilli en moyenne
pendant les vacances pour une eau et
shayne 11 ans apporte les dernières
touches de peinture sur le bar j'aime
bien peindre et les arts manuels aussi
et donner un petit coup de jeune au
point jeunes ça fait pas de mal je
trouve que c'est mieux de venir ici
qu'est de rester chez soi super mario
sonic une fresque conçue en partie par
dounia et raffaella elle peaufine une
autre fresque destiné aux studios de
musique des habitués de cette structure
pour les jeunes de 11 à 15 ans chez soi
et ben on reste assis en train de
regarder la télé rien faire est ici p ya
plein de choses à faire
si je reste chez moi je vais m'ennuyer
et ici au moins on s'amuse ce type de
point jeunes une tradition dans la
politique jeunesse de guyancourt
accessible à tous les adolescents munis
d'une carte d'adhésion pour un tarif de
10 euros par an le but est de créer du
lien social entre les jeunes d'un
certain nombre de jeunes qui se trouvent
sans activité parce que le centre de
loisirs ça les intéresse pas plus
forcément parce qu'ils sont plus grand
donc ses propos ses activités au plus
haut plus âgé il ya donc ces propos des
actifs différentes ce qui peut votre
centre de loisirs qui correspondent plus
à leur tranche d'âge et qui se
retrouvent pas tout seul pendant les
vacances quoi suite à une consultation
un espace jeunes devraient ouvrir en
juin prochain dans le coeur du quartier
villa roi il permettra d'accueillir des
guyancourt toi âgés de 15 à 25 ans